it has been another day of high level
diplomacy but it was the call described
as very direct between us president joe
biden and vladimir putin that showed
just what's at stake
in it the white house says president
biden was clear
if russia undertakes a further invasion
of ukraine the united states together
with allies and partners will respond
decisively and impose swift and severe
costs on russia
the call lasted for just over one hour
and it comes after a week of whirlwind
diplomacy which has seen leaders and
senior politicians visit moscow
it says its key security concerns have
still not been addressed
for now the fear of an invasion remains
the alarm sounding widely with some
western countries including the uk and
the u.s warning their citizens to leave
while they can
we're in
the window when a russian invasion can
start at any time if president putin so
decides
that includes in the coming days
we don't know whether president putin
has made that decision
but we do know that he has put in place
the capacity
uh to act on very short notice
and as this crisis deepens ukrainians
are fearing what comes next in kiev
protesters turned out in the grim cold
to tell the world they were united
against any russian aggression we will
stand we will stand we will protect
ukraine forever we really need to have
this mutual ground to say all the words
we are ready to fight and resist it's
not normal to live like that
in constant fear and action
and anxiety
ukraine is now surrounded by russian
forces the sheer scale of the military
machine and its state of readiness is
making for nervous times
but the kremlin claims this is all just
an exercise and it's accusing the west
of hysteria with the aim of provoking a
conflict
as warnings from western intelligence
agencies about an imminent invasion get
louder
there is a growing sense of anxiety and
unease here in kiev and across the rest
of the country
but despite that there is no sense of
panic for many it's business as usual on
the streets
with people defiant
determined not to let fear run their
lives
and that resilience can be seen in
training sessions like this
here they're teaching basic first aid
and how to take shelter in the event of
a russian attack
i mean russians i don't feel their enemy
i feel the enemy the putin and the
government of the
but the soldiers if they're going to
come to our
land i think that a lot of ukrainian
nearly
more 50 or 60 percent
ready to
to act
more talks are planned in the coming
days but for ukrainians the diplomacy
feels like a world away
they know that this is a dangerous
moment for their country and are vowing
to resist any invasion
but are still hoping it won't come to
that
alex rossi sky news
kiev